y'a plein de maisons aussi mais elles
sont toutes clip hot
j'irais bien voir c'est là le bac votre
côté d'or désolé monsieur
on y va
il y à 40 ans la nuit d'halloween
michael myers a assassiné trois
personnes après cette horrible nuit il
est retourné en hôpital psychiatrique et
il en est plus sorti
[Musique]
depuis cette nuit là suis prier tous les
soirs pour qu'ils s'évadent pourquoi
faire une chose pareille
pour lui faire la peau
[Musique]
depuis ça a eu un accident michael myers
s'étaient jetés
il va retourner à deux villes c'est chez
lui je dois protéger ma famille
t'as pas de système de sécurité karen
faut que tu te fasses itema mots mal
existe c'est pas pour rien si on est
censé avoir peur cette nuit là ça fait
longtemps que je me prépare pour cette
nuit il ne faut surtout pas traîner dans
les rues ce soir c'est un tueur mais
c'est lui qui sera toute cette merde
joyeux alors oui michael
[Musique]